hello everyone and welcome to
uh the horizon forbidden west gameplay
reveal state of play which we are
watching
live we have about 22 seconds remaining
i'm very excited about this game
in general but also because i think
gorilla just make
very pretty environments obviously seen
in horizon but in their previous games
as well
um i'm a huge fan of the entire studio
so
we have eight seven six five
i wonder if it'll be just entirely
gameplay like the loss of spot two one
2-1-1 so
[Music]
maybe we'll get um interviews or
something as well like dying lately this
morning i don't know
let's do it i love state of place that's
so exciting
[Music]
huh
oh what was that that's an audio glitch
in there
hi everyone my name is mathias dion i'm
the game director on horizon forbidden
west
last year we revealed our ambitious new
project korea is out of saying the team
has continued to make okay that's on
their own streams
that's a shame i'm very excited and
honored to give you an update in this
state of play
and in the countdown video leading up to
this moment you have already seen
glimpses of the forbidden west oh i hope
it's not the whole video like it's truly
special for you
almost 14 minutes of gameplay huge
playstation 5
and you don't have to wait any of the
gameplay captured on places oh they
fixed it
and you don't okay let's get right to it
okay i'm very glad it would have been a
huge bummer if the gameplay was out of
sync
cool shoes man
[Music]
easy easy it's okay
you're safe now
right here
oh hey it really hasn't mind if it's on
what happened where's erin
ambush ruins are pulling with raiders
they hit our camp hard we ran and they
chased us down
he he's all about that water was away
[Music]
raiders got machines on their side
closed riders
you should go after aaron if they find
him before you do who knows what they'll
do yeah dude
hydrate king you're injured i have to
don't worry about me i'll make my own
way out
get going okay
at some point you're gonna finish that
that can't be endless
i really like a fit well the leaves very
cool
oh my gosh that's pretty what
that just gave me goosebumps i hope erin
is okay
oh my gosh it's beautiful what the hell
[Music]
very very very nice setting
[Music]
how is this this busy
oh my
[Music]
water looks great
whoa that cool
[Music]
i love that ever the entire video game
community is just oh that's
all right
[Music]
we've just accepted that people can't
see for grass just
all of us are just like oh okay
wow
better be careful there might be more
the sound was really cool though
very nice another one
you like this little tail whip animation
there
i need to get clear
i feel like that was a series of things
we've not seen before
i don't know what he did i can't shake
him
this looks really fluid
maybe i can lose them in here
[Music]
these guys won't give up
i feel like this could look very
different
well that seems scripted because it was
cinematic but maybe it's just
it's just a cinematic um
i feel like that could look very
different depending on how you played
through that
oh pretty
[Music]
i think it's this environment
damn dude the current's strong here
i'm in uh agreement uh with whoever said
that um
a youtube compression even with it it
looks really good youtube does compress
things really badly these videos will
always look better post
live stream um you should generally
always watch them
after the stream but even with that it
looks
gorgeous
never had a chance to play the first one
yeah of course
my friends okay i'm not just the ones
you slaughtered
but when they come looking for me
there's gonna be
[Music]
trouble
[Music]
oh buddy oh my oh my
you guys wouldn't be laughing right my
hammer
you know get moving
this watermelon colored oh my gosh
her hair is like a snake just does not
stop moving there's a strange cut
let's roll i gonna help
which one is uglier look to camp make it
look like bandits we're here
these environments um beautiful
will do i would like to go here please
this must be aaron's camp
raiders made short work of it filthy
[Applause]
awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
all right
you think you can hurt me i love him
though
i don't want to take out watermelon man
damn yeah i do
[Music]
oh my gosh this looks so cool
all right back to the hunt
back to the hunt
ashley butch of course we're talking we
were heading for the old bridge oh i
really would have gone in the other
direction maybe i can cut them off
that's what you just said i really would
have gone the other way and explode all
that [ __ ]
okay not what i expected better get to
higher ground
find a way
so much detail oh my god
very nice
i strongly agree the melee combat looked
very good
more of an incentive to there's the
bridge
do it i think that's supposed to be the
golden gate
i think i know a way to get there first
cool this is so pretty i don't
my brain is confused
i gotta be careful
it's cool as to see the new gameplay
updates
in a video like this without somebody
doing the vo that they normally do
they're not like and here this
is a glider it's cool to just be shown
that this is
cool as hell
[Music]
helps on the way aaron
getting eve vibes riding dinos out here
that's what's happening now
all right take you a while i think mate
i like how we noticed a lot before
noticing the
mech dino she's riding on oh
oh my it's so cute where's the
forbidden west yeah it kind of is yeah
i'm all right with that though it's a
great
game
[Music]
keep moving music
[Music]
super into the synth what the heck this
is very
uh breath of the wild vibes
oh my god this slaps what the hell
gotta slow you down
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh my she really is a soldier
at this point
he looks like he has the like uh anime
cheeks like he's blushing with the
little dots
damn man
yeah i'm loving the way that they've
added to
the formula of the first and the
traversal seems so on point
it went from being you know like
assassin's creedish
do i feel like he having a bit more of
his own playbug
time
hey lord
glad to see me now you bet
i owe you another one come on
but this time i have a present for you
right before the raiders got me he did
good
now let's see where this thing will take
us
[Music]
you always said a storm was coming
yeah and it's almost here i don't know
how old she's supposed to be at this
point
[Music]
i thought that that looked really good
um
[Music]
yeah very into it gameplay footage from
horizon forbidden west
running on playstation 5. we hope you
are as excited about it as we are
this made me more excited about the game
so
success well we have you here we would
like to spotlight some of the new
elements you have just seen in our
gameplay
let's do it and to help with that please
welcome ben mccaw
narrative director on horizon i really
like this way of doing him showing us
all the
also gameplay forbidden west is set a
thousand years in earth's future
after a global catastrophe people live
on in primitive tribes
but they're no longer the dominant
species
giant animal-like machines now roam the
land and they're extremely
dangerous the machines aren't the only
threat in the forbidden west
a stream so alternatively it's spreading
across the land
and it won't be long before it strangles
all light that's what all the red is
everywhere
our hero is the only one who can stop
the blight
but to do that she and her companions
will have to comb through the ruins of
the old world to find the technology
they need it's amazing in this quest how
open wild is this going to be loyal
friend aaron there's too much detail
loans of san francisco to find a crucial
piece of technology
aaron encounters raiders from a rebel
faction of the tanakh
tribe they are vicious fighters but even
worse
they've acquired the power to override
machines
to rescue errand alloy winds up fighting
them but first
she must cross the ruins to reach their
camp
we face a lot of obstacles as we
traverse the ruins of san francisco
to overcome them we've killed it's
changed a lot of new skills gentlemen
someone who used to live there and the
focus scanner it doesn't look like this
i don't know people
that allow free climbing anywhere in the
open world
the forecast is
allows you to safely descend from great
heights or surprise enemies
that's gonna be really fun with the
diving mask you can stay submerged
as long as you like and take your time
to plan a path around amphibious
machines
or boost through strong underwater
currents
and to speed up overland travel a
variety of machines can be overridden
and used as mounts
or in combat combat in horizon from
middlewest puts a strong emphasis on
tactics and player choice
for close range combat the spear is an
excellent option it looks really good
there's a range of combos that have
different uses and effects valor surges
add a unique set of special abilities
one of which can like weapons back
nearby enemies
the spear can be charged to create a
high damage effect that can take down
even the stronger enemies
a wide array of different weapons is
quickly accessible via the weapon wheel
a slingshot with adhesive grenades to
temporarily stall machines
both with arrows that can strip armor
and expose weak spots
a powerful launcher that fires spikes
that explode on impact
smoke bombs the temporarily blinding
yeah the smoke bombs looked very cool
i wasn't sure exactly what's going on
the full game has many more unique
weapons and each of them can be upgraded
but more on that another time
the player will need to be smart and
creative and use all of the combat
options we have shown
to deal with a large variety of deadly
machines
sun wings in the sky clawstriders and
tremor tusks on land
stem walls in the water even the
seemingly harmless burrs that you saw
briefly swim by
they are all dangerous and even more so
when overridden by human rebels i'm
loving the colors
we've only scratched the surface of the
rebel threat as aloy will fight them
in many forms throughout the game and to
defeat them
she must explore the open world to
uncover the secret behind their power
and how that secret is related to her
quest to stop the blight
this is just one of the mysteries she'll
unravel as her journey through the
forbidden west
takes many twists and turns
it's time to wrap it up we will have
more updates close to launch and
everyone here at gorilla can't wait for
you to experience the fool man i caught
waiting
it looks awesome any time
uh yeah i thought that looked fantastic
um i frequently
i'm very impressed by graphics in these
presentations but uh
the thing that made this one i think
especially impressive
i assume that's probably gonna be it um
was
the uh the
updates to the gameplay like i said i
just think that that gameplay looks so
fluid
if there's a lot more verticality and
the levels um you know it's such a good
way to
make a sequel uh is to
you know not just have more of the same
thing again they've actually really well
showcased in that that gameplay reveal i
think some of the actual gameplay
changes that look like massive
improvements that make
things that i may have found like
slightly more tedious in the first game
a lot more fun in the next one like i
love to see that um again graphics blow
me away all the time but that's not what
i'm looking for
when i'm like no i want to play a game i
could i could play a game that looks
stunning and doesn't have great gameplay
that gameplay looked really fun so
i thought that looked absolutely
fantastic there was no mention of a
release date
i believe all the footage was on
playstation 5 i think they said
um yeah very very neat exciting stuff
there so that one
i so often watch these conferences um as
i did with dying light too earlier today
and my reaction is like oh this looked
really cool
but i already thought that it looked
cool you know
where i'm like well yeah but you didn't
give me like any huge hugely new
information
from what that was about whereas this
one i walk away wanting the game more
than i did previously so
also obviously full disclosure i work
for playstation you have to know that
these are all my genuine opinions 100 it
would be illegal for me to
do anything else i can say whatever i
want they don't have any rules but
whenever i'm super positive about
something i feel like i always need to
disclose
um just so people know but yes if you
had any issues watching this video uh
streams always get really compressed on
youtube they make everything look ugly i
imagine that you can now watch it in
in 4k probably so thank you all for
joining me
i appreciate it um
and i think the next thing that i've
officially used up
absolutely all of my lunch break time
today so that is we're done here
uh i am planning to stream far cry
tomorrow because there's also a far cry
reveal tomorrow
um i will obviously put the little live
waiting thing here on youtube
if that's the case and yeah while i
still do largely stream on twitch
uh for any like conference trailer
reaction things that are going to stay
on youtube just because that's like the
kind of coverage that i have on my
youtube channel which which is for more
playing game stuff so
yeah thank you all for joining me for
this one it was really fun had a great
time
game looks awesome i will see you guys
later bye